welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
working with a web server so so far
we've talked about how to write the html
and css but
we haven't really talked about how to
actually get your files up on the web
now for the most part we're not going to
need to do this for our class but i
think it's clearly something that's
important if you actually want to
create a real web page so it's
definitely worth talking about
so so far if you think about what we've
been doing for our class if you think
about what's been going on with homework
you've been creating files on your
laptop and you've been loading them into
the web browser on your laptop
and so we're really taking advantage of
one aspect of how the web browser works
so the web browser actually has several
different tasks
it understands how to use http to make
requests to
different web servers and then it
understands when the files come back how
to actually render and display those
and we've only been taking advantage of
rendering and displaying
the files after they've been placed on
our computer and we have not been taking
advantage of
the first part where we request files
from a server
we've been generating the files on our
own laptop and loading them
on our own laptop so clearly
if we want to have other people be able
to see our web pages we need to put the
files on the server
where they can be sent to lots of
different people
so what we need to do here is we need to
basically reverse the process here
we need to take the files the html the
css the image files
whatever files are associated with our
web page we need to take those files
from our laptop where we've been we've
been playing around with them and
experimenting with them and testing them
then we need to actually put them on a
server and so that's what this video is
all about
okay so there's a number of different
steps and i will go over each of these
steps in detail but let's just
take a quick overview here okay we need
to get a
web hosting service so we need to have
an actual server we can put those files
on
we need to create and test the files and
testing them locally as you've been
doing for the homeworks that's totally
fine
that is a common practice um but once
we're convinced that the files seem to
be working fine
we need to figure out how to get them
onto the web server so that's going to
take several things first of all we need
to choose
the software we're going to use to
transfer the files over to the server
and then we're going to have to figure
out where to put them on the server
and then of course we're actually going
to transfer them and then finally
we should double check our files and
make sure everything's working properly
and we'll be spending some time at the
end of this video talking specifically
about things that can go wrong and
things to be checking for
okay so you need have a web hosting
service
um stanford provides hosting for student
files so
um every student at stanford has a
directory
that they can place files on that can be
accessed from web.stanford.edu
many internet service providers also
provide web hosting so if you
graduate from stanford you can check
with whoever's providing your internet
service they may provide hosting for
files
um there's quite a number of companies
that also provide
some basic web hosting services and then
if you really get into it
you can get professional grade web
hosting like amazon web services
all right so as i suggested um creating
and testing files on your own computer
is a great idea
and that's what we've been doing here
you can't test the files on an actual
web server
um and you know if we get a little bit
more advanced
and you may want to do some of that on
your own files but
uh the main thing to keep in mind is if
you do transfer files over the web
server
and you have not tested them those files
are live
so you know people visit your website
and you are in the process of testing
your files to make sure they're working
they're going to see stuff that's
potentially busted
so uh the way around this is
you can have a special test location on
your server and do some testing there
or you can actually run a separate
test server okay as far as file transfer
software goes in general you're going to
want a program that supports a secure
file transfer
protocol or sftp so there is an earlier
version of
this protocol just called ftp it's still
usable but
in general it's recommended you use the
secure version sftp
and in fact stanford will not let you
connect to the stanford servers with
ftp you need to use secure ftp these are
a couple
sample programs you might consider for
using sftp securefx on windows
or fetch on the mac and in fact these
are both available for free
to stanford students and faculty and
staff
and here's a website if you haven't
already visited this website
this is a handy website to know about
it's called essential stanford software
or ess
you can go to it from ess.stanford.edu
it'll make you log in with your su netid
and there's a bunch of software there
that you can download for free
including secure fx and fetch for our
sftp transfers these sftp programs are
likely to work for any service provider
that you're working with
any web hosting solution that you're
working with getting the files over
there
different hosting solutions may also
have other ways of getting the files
over there
so for example stanford has a web
interface
if you go to afs.stanford.edu
you can upload and download files using
that website um our experience has been
that
in general the students do find it a
little bit more straightforward maybe a
little bit easier working with
afs afs.stanford.edu rather than getting
a separate secure
ftp program but
you know as you start doing more and
more work you will probably find that
there's more to learn
and maybe it's a little bit harder
getting used to sftp but once you
understand how sftp works
you may actually find that it uh that
using it
actually streamlines your process quite
a bit so
if you're just doing something simple
like the homework files and using
something simple like afs.stanford.edu
would work fine but if you're working
with a
actual large website you're probably
going to want to use something a little
bit more sophisticated
okay so uh we need to determine what
location to put our files in
and all stanford students as i mentioned
before
do have web hosting from stanford
so stanford has a file server that you
can use to
store different files this is sometimes
referred to as the leland
system uh and in the leland system
you've got a directory there
and within that directory there's a
special directory already created for
you called www
this is where you put your web page
stuff so
that that wwe directory if you put
things into the www directory they are
now
on the web so don't put anything in the
www
directory unless you want other people
to be able to see it because
it is publicly available and the read
write permissions are set so that
anybody can view the files
in that directory if you put something
in the www directory
people will be able to access it using
the url i put here
http colon slash web.stanford.edu
tilde and then whether your su net id is
and then if they just end it with a
closing slash it will load the
index.html as we talked about in a
previous video
that's the default at stanford
loadingindex.html
or if they follow the tildesu netid
slash with
the actual name of a html file that's
what will be loaded up
okay so we now have some idea of what
our file
transfer options are and we now know
where to put the files as far as
stanford goes
um if you're working with a
web server other than stanford whoever
is providing your web hosting should
tell you
what location to place the files for uh
web hosting okay so we're gonna go ahead
and transfer the files over
i'm showing you an image here of
securefx in action
and this basically has two sets of
directions there's a set of directories
and files on the left which is what's on
my laptop and there's a
set of directories and files on the
right that show what's on the server and
i've got a whole bunch of junk in here
and you can actually see my
www directory there has a whole bunch of
sub folders in it
um but you know if you haven't done
anything you will have an empty www
directory
and i'm not going to talk too much about
how to transfer files over it's going to
vary depending on
which software you're using and
it's generally going to be pretty
straightforward basically you can take
items on the left and either drag them
over to the right or
often you can just double click over
them on the right the other thing that i
think is worth mentioning is you can
either transfer individual files over or
you can just transfer entire directories
over
so if you've got uh you know some sort
of a
fairly deep nested structure of
files and folders for your website and
you've got it up working on your laptop
and you want to transfer them over to
the server you don't need to transfer
the individual files over you can just
transfer the whole directory over and
it should work okay once you get them
over there
um you know even if they work fine in
your laptop
you do want to do some extra checking
once you transfer them over
so if we're a professional probably what
we're going to do
is we're going to have a separate
testing location other than where the
files ultimately are going to end up
or we're going to have a test server you
may occasionally run it to these
test servers um actually running on the
web sometimes people just leave them up
and even have links to them so if you
see something that looks like this
www.example.edu colon
8080 that is actually the test server
that 8080
that's a port number um cs106e students
who talked a little about port numbers
being used to identify
specific programs running on a
particular computer
on the internet and the normal port
number for
http is 80 and an 8080 is used as a
test uh test server for http
okay what sort of problems might you run
into
so i suggest that you should double
check all your stuff once you move over
to the web
you can put in a temporary testing
location and then rename the testing
location when you're done you can put
them in a temporary
server location and then move them over
when you're done
or you know if it's just some
fun stuff that you're putting on the web
you can just put it in its ultimate
destination not bother with the testing
server stuff
um and just assume that you know if it's
just your friends that are going to be
seeing it they're probably not going to
happen to visit your website at the
exact same time that you're putting the
files up
okay so what can go wrong why am i
telling you to double check all your
stuff well
here's some common things that could go
wrong first of all if you get a 404
error
that probably means your files are in
the wrong location or it could mean that
you're misspelling something in the file
name
so those are well the misspelling is
actually fairly common
although if you test it thoroughly on
the
laptop before transferring over we'll
actually take a look in a couple minutes
about some issues with file names but
hopefully you would have caught that if
you get a 403 error
remember that means permission not found
that means that the permissions on the
directory are messed up
this used to be an issue at stanford
because the www directories were not
pre-created
and students had to create them manually
and if you didn't set the permissions
right
basically people visiting the directory
would be there but people trying to
visit from the web
the server would say hey you don't have
permission to
view that file but at this point
stanford does have that www directory
already created for all students with
the permission set properly
presumably if you're working with an
outside web hosting service they will
set the permissions
properly or you know if you're doing
something really sophisticated like
amazon web services well then it's up to
you
don't bring out the big guns and use the
sophisticated services unless you know
what they're doing they can get
pretty complicated um amazon has a huge
number of options and
it can get very very complex very
quickly all right
i also recommend that you just double
check every link on your website and
double check your images and make sure
that they're all working
um what can go wrong well first of all
don't use absolute references we've
talked about this before
when we talked about creating links and
definitely don't use
file references remember absolute
references are references to specific
locations on specific computers
if you were testing on your laptop and
you had absolute references and now you
move it to
your web hosting service like for
example stanford
those files are now in a different
location so those absolute references
are now absolute references to your
original laptop they are not
absolute references to the new location
of the file so
in general just don't use absolute
references unless you're linking to
somebody else's webpage
in which case that other person's web
page is still located wherever it was
out on the web before it's still located
there after you move your files over to
stanford so that's not going to have an
effect but
as far as links to web pages within your
website
or references to anything within your
website for example images within your
website
you need to use relative references for
that
okay i mentioned this a little earlier
when we talk about four fours that there
are some issues that can come up with
file names
uh here's what you're going to do to
avoid those issues
name your files with all lower case
letters no uppercase letters just
lowercase letters
you can use the digits 0 through 9 you
can use dashes
and then just for the dot html or the
dot css you can use the period
that's all i recommend it is possible to
use upper and lowercase letters but
here's what can happen so it turns out
when you're testing the files on your
own computer like
you created the files on your laptop you
did some testing on your laptop
laptops and some servers don't actually
care if you get the case and the letters
wrong so if you mix the upper and lower
case letters that works just fine
so if i've got a file named test.html
with a capital t
and i create a link to it using ahf
equals
lowercase t test.html that will work
fine on some
servers and it will generally work just
fine when you're testing locally just on
files on your laptop
but some servers including stanford's
are much more finicky
and the upper and lower case must match
so in this case if i had a file named
test.html the capital t
and i tried to link it to it with the
lowercase t
it wouldn't work it would show hey i
don't know what that file is
and keep in mind this happens with links
this is also going to happen with things
like
if you've got an img with an src
and the case is wrong on your src it's
also going to just show up as a broken
image so
um i think you can get this to work
as long as you're really careful and you
always use the correct upper lower case
for the names
i think it's easier just to just not
deal with that and just name all your
files just lowercase
okay i also mentioned that you should
just use the dash
you can use other characters but they
will cause problems
and there are some issues with them so
you know i think one thing that you may
occasionally run into for example is if
somebody puts a space in the name of the
file
you can link to it but basically you
need to replace the spaces in all of
your
references to that file with the percent
20.
um that's actually a reference to the
original ascii code for the space
character
so you know it's better to not deal with
these
percent 20 and co coatings uh
these are sometimes referred to as url
encodings uh
and just you know just don't use any
weird characters the dash does not need
any special encodings
obviously the letters don't need any
special encodings neither do the
digits zero through nine so just limit
yourself to using those
in in your name and that should solve a
lot of problems
okay another issue that i've seen
students run into is
having the wrong type of image format so
here are the image formats you should be
using you should limit yourself to
jpegs pngs gifs
and then we haven't really talked about
this all i mentioned it very briefly
there's something called svg which
allows us to store images using an
object
slash vector remember those two are
synonymous object or vector
graphics format instead of the jpeg png
gifs which are using the bitmap also
sometimes referred to as raster
format so we might talk about svg later
in the quarter but
you know regardless these are the four
formats that you can use
there are some other formats that you
might commonly run into
those will not necessarily work on the
web so
if you're taking images with an ios
device for example apple has a new
format
heic it's a good format but it is not
web compatible and even
apple's web browsers if you were to
serve a file up using this format
they're not going to display it so
don't don't use the heic format you need
to convert it
also google has been pushing this webp
and webm formats one of them's for
photos and one of us for
movies um these are not supported by
a little bit over 50 of the web browsers
currently in use in the united states
one of the big holdouts is it turns out
that apple is not supporting it on their
safari
uh web browser so um
i strongly don't recommend using either
these formats
so if you're using something with a
format like heic
apple's htic or webp you you are going
to have to
reformat your your information into
one of these other formats jpeg png gif
or
potentially svg um i do want to caution
you that you do need to use a
photo editing program like say photoshop
i have had some students just try and
rename the files
um and it would be nice that the
computers were smart enough to handle
that now but they aren't currently there
yet
so you know definitely use something
like photoshop uh
there's some built-in software
[Music]
windows and i suspect the mac as well
have some built-in
basic image editing software and they
can pro
probably do the transfer as well if you
don't want to spring for photoshop
okay so that gives you some ideas on how
to take your files
and put them up on the web um
i guess the last thing i should say you
guys have probably
had this drilled into at this point but
be cautious on information that you put
up on the web
uh everybody can see it um you know
think very very carefully if you want to
have your name and phone number up there
i mentioned one of the earlier lectures
about putting email up there
that gets all scooped up by automated
programs
i haven't heard anything about automated
programs looking for phone numbers and
adding them to
you know telemarketing calls but that
would not surprise me and it certainly
happens with email addresses that are
put on the web
and of course you know you want to be
very careful about putting stuff like
your home address and other information
like that online
all right so that's it for what you need
to do
in order to get your files actually
online i'll talk to you in the next
video
you